our next question is from Kat and
Sacramento that's just wondering if you
had any tips on how to worry less and be
a little less than this license because
that is something that I really struggle
with and I waste so much time worrying
about every little thing it just causes
me unnecessary stress so Ryan it sounds
to me like Kat wants to she want some
tips on how to be the way she phrased it
was be less indecisive and the thing
that I think about is to be less
indecisive you have to be more decisive
right right and so instead of being less
indecisive it's really about how can I
be more decisive yeah in my day to day
decisions so I've got some basic tips
because she asked for tips about
worrying less and I promise I won't
spend a whole lot of time on these
because they're basic but they're
important they're thereof they're a
foundation to consider the first off um
are you sleeping enough hmm are you
exercising enough I know for me those
two things will radically reduce my
anxiety in fact if I'm feeling really
anxious and overwhelmed one of the
things I'll do is go try to take a nap
it doesn't always work for me but I will
lay down at least and I'll put on my
headphones with a brain FM app and I
will just set it for either 20 30 or 45
minutes and I would just lay there and
let my mind sort of wander it's it's
meditative sometimes awful actually fall
asleep and I'll wake up like oh I'm not
feeling as anxious now because your
breath slows your body calms down even
if you don't actually fall into one of
the stages of sleep you feel a lot
better afterward because it's it's like
defragging your your hard drive and your
mind so to speak so and exercise for me
it can be something just quick and brisk
you know there's a hill right by my
apartment so I'll walk up that hill and
then walk around the block and walk back
down and it gets my heartbeat going for
15-20 minutes or so and then all of a
sudden once you do that you you become
more in sync with with your body
absolutely I just ordered an exercise
bike so that I can make sure I'm getting
my heart rate up
and whenever I feel anxious I'm just
gonna hop on that for 20 maybe 30
minutes and that'll totally change my my
state yeah it's good agree with you more
man meditation helps a lot too
any time any when I'm meditating on a
regular basis I am able to will a be
more decisive but my stress level is is
much more under control
yeah meaning I mean all it does is it
allows you to take and let well this is
how it works for me it allows me to take
a thought that is really really
bothering me causing me stress
interrupting my day and I can kind of
compartmentalize that and say yes that
is a problem
that is something that well maybe it's
something I can't address maybe it's you
know we were talking about my dad last
episode maybe it's something there we're
like I there's nothing I can do I am I
am at a point where it's like I look at
that thought and I say you know what man
like I've done everything I can and I'm
going to go ahead and continue to focus
about going about my day and not let
this angst ruin it yeah ruin the rest of
my day and and if it wasn't for the
meditate and I don't meditate like if if
I'm meditating every days for five to
ten minutes a day sometimes it'll turn
into 20 30 minutes but like Moriah now
we've been trying to meditate with each
other for at least five minutes a day
and when I do that I am able to go
through that process a lot easier hands
down dude it's very much like like to
sleep I would think the same scientific
reasoning our friend Dan Harris says one
minute is meditating so like it's it's
it's sort of a gateway into doing longer
I mean Dan meditates for two hours a day
every day yeah it's just phenomenal
and I think it's radically changed his
life now
meditation is not the miracle drug it is
simply one tool and I like the idea of
the the metaphor of compartmentalizing
something for a second light like the
thoughts about your dad clear they're
not useful right you've already come to
terms with you you've dealt with it
you've had a funeral for the
relationship as you talked about in the
last episode but taking that thought and
sort of put it in this compartment and
then letting that compartment go yeah
and in a way if the patient allows you
to let go of those thoughts yeah it
allows me to or
helps me to be more accepting of life it
helps me to well basically helps me to
lower my expectations and raise my
standards yes my standard is is like yes
I'm not going to ruminate on stress but
I don't expect that there's gonna be
zero stress in my life and if you don't
have time to meditate
you can't take a nap right now one thing
that really helps me out there's some
science behind this just within the last
few years if you take six deep breaths
oh yeah and for ever reason it's six
like that the science shows that minimum
of six you just do though let it out if
you can hold it for you know a few
seconds as well six of those will
radically change your state and it will
radically reduce your anxiety levels now
maybe it's reduced about thirty percent
that's a pretty radical reduction for
Ella I've realized I was trying to get
her to do the six and she just started
hyperventilating because 6 is a big
number for a five-year-old because
trying to do six of anything is like
just too much as you just saw it would
produce more anxiety in her am i all
right
elevating you take 60 breaths issues and
so now it's like hey let's take one deep
breath let's hold it in together for a
few seconds and then just let it out and
and that really helps and then if I can
get her past one then it's can we do one
more deep breath if I can get her to do
two or three it often changes her state
and then when she becomes less anxious I
become less anxious another thing that I
do when I'm doing non creative works if
I'm checking emails or doing phone calls
whatever I wear a wristwatch and I'll
have it on now but with a 22 minute
timer on it so you can set it on your
phone or whatever and it just vibrates
every 22 minutes and I get up and I will
do some form of exercise I'll either do
like 20 squats or I'll do 10 pull-ups or
I will do 50 pushups just something to
get changed my state and I go right back
to it to working so less than a minute
or so less than two minutes for sure and
I go back to 20 minutes of email or
whatever and that that continues to to
help me with with my anxiety
you mentioned meditation
so I think the thing we need to ask Ryan
that we need to ask Kat here is the
thing that you we asked each other at
the top of this like what cam what is
actually triggering your anxiety because
you might say that like well I don't
know I'm just anxious all the time I
don't know what's actually trigger my
anxiety what's the decision-making she
said right right but so let's keep going
let's follow that that anxiety to what
what are the specific decisions my guess
is there are certain decisions for her
that are really difficult and so she
puts them off right she's making
decisions every single day so it's not
every decision that is making her
anxious okay maybe she decided to drink
water right now that's not making her
anxious and so what are the decisions
that are making you anxious what are
those triggers and then instead of
hiding from them instead of running away
from them you want to become brave
enough to to run toward them right yeah
and so that worried that worry is just a
word that means fear basically right and
so it reminded me of this this essay
that I've got here somewhere about fear
minimalism kills fear this is on our
website this is an oldie but a goodie
this is from 2010 it's a good woman and
there are some exercises in here I just
want to read so you and I when we first
started the minimalists calm we started
with this 21-day journey into minimalism
which which followed your 21 days of the
packing party and letting go of those
things but along the way there were sort
of these aha moments and one of them had
to do with fear and so this is what we
wrote about that and we'll put a link to
this essay in the show notes as well
we're all afraid of something some of
our fears are obvious spiders Heights
exes other fears are less pronounced
less obvious like the fear of loss the
loss of things the loss of acceptance
the loss of love sometimes we're afraid
to give up what we think we have fear
traps us it prevents us from growing it
prevents us from contributing to other
people it prevents us from living happy
satisfied fulfilled free lives so think
about that for a second if you're
worrying you're you're really just
afraid that
Woori prevents you from having a
fulfilled free life it gets in the way
of satisfaction quite often fear is the
antithesis of freedom it is by
definition constricting we often hold on
to things because we're afraid to get
rid of them we fear losing those things
because we think we might need them
we don't just fear the loss of these
things though we fear the loss of what
these things might mean to us in some
distant hypothetical future when you say
it out loud it sounds ridiculous try it
I'm afraid of getting rid of this
t-shirt it's something we actually worry
about right yeah well if I get rid of
this I'm afraid I'm gonna miss it I'm
afraid I'm gonna want it one day I'm
afraid that I'm gonna need it just in
case I'm afraid that a friend's gonna
need it just in case
right right I'm afraid that the
Garrity's t-shirt because it could have
a serious impact on my life in the
future sounds ridiculous right so
there's an obvious question we must ask
ourselves when we're holding on to
something why am i afraid of getting rid
of this now something can be a physical
thing why am i afraid to get but it
could also be like why are you actually
afraid Kat why are you afraid of making
a decision mm-hmm what what are you
actually afraid of and then saying it
out loud it might seem banal on the
surface but it's actually a great
question to ask when you're faced with
these difficult decisions give it a try
so you don't want to say no to that
person what am I really afraid of mm-hmm
yeah you can't write you good oh no go
for it well you can't write the novel
you've been dreaming of writing why what
are you afraid of I can't learn to play
the instrument I've always wanted to
play I mean why what are you Fred if
you're gonna be bad of course gonna be
bad at first everyone who ever picked it
with horror was bad at first everyone
who ever I'm still pretty bad yes you've
picked up a guitar a lot of times mm-hmm
so a vine I'm still pretty bad at it and
that's okay
and so it goes on I can't exercise and
eat healthy foods
I mean this is something we tell
ourselves like I can't I couldn't do
that it's just too difficult it's not
realistic for me to exercise every day
insomnia that made me think man food is
such a like it's the social media it's
another social media it's another
pacifier to anxiety yeah and so I can't
eat healthy why what are you afraid of
right
I can't quit the job I hate to pursue
what I'm passionate about why what are
you afraid of I can't fill in the blank
what are you afraid of and I think it's
important to ask that question the
answer this question is almost always
ridiculous I'm afraid people won't like
me anymore I'm afraid people won't love
me anymore I'm afraid people won't
respect me anymore chances are you have
manufactured these false fears and it is
these manufactured fears that keep you
from doing what you want to do or in the
case of our physical items it's the fear
that heat it's the fears that keep you
from getting rid of the certain things
that have no real value things they
don't have any real meaning in your life
we have good news though fear is a
choice and thus anxiety is often a
choice when you figure out what are
those real what are those triggers right
and so I will I'll put a link to this or
shaaka put a link to this in the show
notes we can you can take a look at it
we've got some exercises in here that
you can do to to get rid of those fears
in addition asking that question what
are you afraid of I like that essay the
that's an awesome one did another good
one I think you actually have it there
the paths oh yes so from cat eye
I totally feel you on this being scared
to make a decision especially the
important decisions am I going to go to
college or am I gonna just try and do
something on my own am I going to go
into debt to buy a big house or am I
just gonna continue to rent I mean there
are these major decisions that are can
be paralyzing because if we make the
wrong decision right it can be
detrimental or it can set us back five
years or so so I totally I can empathize
because I've been there
and and and I'm sure cat is is
experiencing a little bit of that but
cat here's what I will say I don't know
you're gonna read that path as paths
essay or not we're gonna save that for
the the patreon post grip but there's no
separate essay here to talk about - good
yeah let's and we can put a link it for
the past association on you can put a
note in the in the show notes there for
cat to read but you know ultimately cat
like you've got you do have to figure
out a way to trust in yourself she has
to figure out a way
- to make these decisions without
without that fear of the consequence and
what I mean by that is is so she's
deciding to buy a house this can be a
good or bad decision yes there is not
it's there's not just a blanket
statement to say well buying a house is
a good or bad decision right so the way
that cat is going to make good decisions
as she's going to consider every single
possibility every option she has she's
going to consider how it affects her
life how it affects the people around
her how it affects their lives and
ultimately cat like you're gonna have to
make the best decision given with the
given information that you have yeah oh
God I wouldn't say but here's the thing
cat is sometimes you're gonna make a bad
decision it's gonna happen we all make
bad decisions sometimes yeah but if you
have done everything you can to make the
best decision for yourself and something
goes wrong that's good news
yes you get to learn from it yeah you
get to learn to not make that decision
again and sometimes the the bad
decisions can be really bad sometimes
they can be fairly innocuous right
pretty benign and so here's this essay
and other ones called the worst thing
that could happen this is from our book
essential
it says risk scares the crap out of us
and this is gonna be a great question
for cat - there's a couple questions in
here many of us associate risk with
failure failure with pain yeah we're
told we must take plenty of risks to
succeed the success must be painful
right not necessarily when it comes to
challenging our preconceived notions
about risks the common platitude until
question tossed around by kind-hearted
friends and self-help gurus is what's
the worst thing that could happen and so
something you think about that for a
second like sometimes well yeah okay I'm
gonna do that what's the worst thing
that can do that was like my grandpa's
biggest piece of advice to me really
yeah he's like any decision that you
have to make think about the worst thing
that can happen right if you can accept
that scenario if you can accept that
consequence then do it right yeah and so
so actually made me do some really
shitty decisions growing up but I think
that's why this essay is helpful because
it helps you ask another question yes
absolutely so truth be told some risks
are fairly benign letting
most your material possessions asking a
cute guy or girl for his phone number
writing the first page you have your
phone number Josh yes
snow ice writing the first page of the
book you've always wanted to write
what's the worst thing that can happen
likely nothing at all like like if you
do at and you really like someone you
want to asked with her phone what's the
worst thing it can happen get rejected
yeah
literally nothing happens though right
yeah you're rejected and nothing happens
what happens if you write the first page
of the book and it's terrible nothing
nothing actually have you delete it you
can't prove anything happen right
there's no real risk in these harmless
endeavors other risks however probably
should scare the [ __ ] out of you
skydiving purchasing a home quitting
your job what's the worst thing that
could happen well some pretty awful
stuff actually death debt and poverty
respectively that doesn't mean you
shouldn't take these risks and meaning
it means you should approach each risk
with logic reason and intuition
you should peer over the edge before
taking your proverbial leap and if it
makes sense then leap because not
leaping can be a much bigger risk
you